dans l' affaire grégory l'article publié
ce matin par nos confrères du
républicain lorrain met vraiment le feu
aux poudres globalement il est question
d'irrégularités et d'erreurs
d'interprétation du code de procédure
pénale mais quand on y regarde d'un peu
plus près on ne retient qu'une petite
phrase qui est celle ci les enquêteurs
seraient allés jusqu'à fabriquer des
preuves matérielles pour confondre
christine villemin accusations terribles
surtout quand on connaît les passions
soulevées par cette affaire le point
avec patrice pollet sur cette photo
georges jacobs l'oncle de jean marie
villemin et de bernard laroche il est
ici dans sa cave et dans ses mails qu'un
reste deux cordelettes semblable à celui
que des policiers en civil serait venu
chercher par deux fois en 1984 voilà ce
que dit monsieur jacob il dit qu'il a
remis de l'accord de l'état à des
policiers alors nous on a comme tout bon
journaliste
enfin je pense on a essayé de savoir à
quel type de policiers n'avaient plus
les données on lui a dit il est en
uniforme dit non non non la pj nancy il
a bien précisé qu'il s'agissait de la pj
de nancy on l'a pas forcé on ne l'a pas
violée ni agressée pour qu'il nous donne
ce type de déférer et encore une fois ce
moment là on en a tiré aucune conclusion
ensuite au fil des lignes le scénario
est expliqué les policiers du srpj de
nancy aurait déposé des morceaux de
corps de halle est récupérée chez
georges jacobs donc la maison des villes
en tout treize morceaux vtt
effectivement découvert il n'en faut pas
plus et après examen le 5 juillet 85 le
juge lambert inculpe christine villemin
pour l'assassinât de son fils grégory
retrouvé noyé dans la vologne les mains
entravées par de la ficelle de même
nature ce soir l'ensemble des syndicats
de policiers crient au scandale certains
ont été reçus ce matin au ministère de
l'intérieur il porte plainte pour
diffamation
ce que je sais c'est que les quatre
policiers qui sont donc impliqués entre
guillemets dans cette affaire
connaissent parfaitement eux ce qu'ils
ont fait les actes qu'ils ont diligenté
dans le cadre de cette affaire et ce
sont eux qui vont se constituer partie
civile il est bien évident que nous
compte tenu des déclarations du parquet
général qui a connaissance du dossier
que nous donc nous allons soutenir leur
action quant aux journalistes
responsables de l'anc est ils ont été
entendus mardi dernier à dijon par le
nouveau magistrat instructeur simon le
juge d'instruction a donc depuis mardi
dernier tous ces nouveaux éléments
enquête dans son dossier oui de son côté
à dijon le procureur de la république a
déclaré ce soir que les accusations
portées contre les policiers de nancy ne
reposait sur aucun fondement